clayton kershaw making his first outing
since july 3rd facing off for the
diamondbacks team that in 17 starts
career dodger stadium has gone 10-1 with
a 1-5-9
he's always loved pitching here at
dodger stadium but even the ultimate
success against these diamondbacks with
clayton coming back it's going to be
fastball curveball slider
he gets a swing and a miss and a curved
ball and opens his night with a
strikeout of ahmed and that's how his
night begins the pitch swung on and hit
sharply by third into the left field
corner add to that 388 average he'll go
into sega based standing with a one-up
double right down that third base line
so now it's two on and two out it's up
to josh rohan
266 and 11 home runs
fastball rojas dunks it into left center
you can tell martin coming around and
the diamondbacks strike first dodgers
throw it around the infield and the
runners move up carson at third rojas at
second it's one nothing diamondbacks
kershaw brings him an 0-2 and strikes
him out with the slider for arizona gets
one zach gallon it's been an
injury-riddled season for him three il
stints
and as he's pitched through that
he's stronger to get traction although
lately he's looked more like the guy
that they saw the first two seasons in
the majors he's got a 2-1-9 era over his
last four games
and mookie rips it off the glove of a
leaping third baseman rojas and down the
left field line around first and heading
into second with a leadoff double as
moki bets his 26th double of the season
first and third for seeger zego one of
the dodgers hottest hitters
sends it home there's a ground ball
that's through into right center field
to base it turner will turn second on
his way to third bet scores it's an rbi
single for corey seeger and the game is
tied at one go ahead running third
turner at the plate
that is rifled into left field and the
dodgers promptly come back and take the
lead
turner is in the score seeger blazing
around third here's the throw it's late
two-run double for justin turner just
like that it's three welcome speaking of
football stars here is scranton
pennsylvania's jake mccarthy in the
lineup tonight
mccarthy jumps on the first one and kind
of squeaks it right through the infield
he's aboard a one-ounce single here he
comes with the 2-2 pitch and he got him
with a curve again for the second time
tonight third strikeout in the game two
on and one out second one given up by
gallon here's a 2-2 pitch
swinging a miss struck him out well
whatever it was it worked yeah
worked that time good change up maybe
that's what said strike him out
again the o2 detroit turner
and the ground ball hit sharply but
right to sing it young to the bag ahead
of bets and that'll in the ending had
him played perfectly
four unassisted
nz and the dodgers
lava couple it's a 3-1 dodger lead
here's the 3-2 and he got him to chase
the high festival would have been ball
four but it's a strikeout instead for
gallon
his third of the night and that's one
out to start the third inning yeah nice
pitch up in the zone
there's another dodger who chased a high
heater against gallon he's getting some
strikeouts with that pitch he's punched
down three of the last four
not a fastball lifts it deep to right
field jake mccarthy has room and just
shy of the warning track by about two
steps makes the catch bellinger's out
the dodgers are on the third no runs no
hits no airs nobody left we ended the
fourth michelle retired the side in
order in the third it took him five
pitches to retire the side strikes him
out with a weak flail in a minute
first strikeout for kershaw two down
runner at second base and jake mccarthy
up here's his payoff
he struck him out good slider right
there
two strikeouts in the inning one hit one
man left no dodger errors he gets mookie
up there second and third one away
flight into right
gavin lux goes back to tag up it's not
very deep jake mccarthy makes the catch
lux is going to try it here comes the
play at the plate safe is lux and the
dodgers lead it four to one on the
sacrifice fly by bets yeah good timing
by lux they are going to review it
and it is close
that may be what they're trying to
determine was his foot
up above the plate or was it on the
plate
wow
[Applause]
wow
zach gallon will lead off the top of the
fifth inning pitcher face clayton
kershaw
zach gallon lines the first ball that he
sees and gavin works makes the play not
an easy one to make
kind of a knuckling lighter and it's
going to be just that one hitter for
kershaw here comes dave roberts
and that will do it for his return a
successful one at that for clayton
kershaw
bickford who overall has been great this
season is holding on a little bit harder
times over his last 10 eras above five
3-2
swung on popped up right side shallow
right but right in the back of the
infield out of the outfield grass
is max muncie and he will make the catch
punches this one to the other side
backhanded by seeger tough play no
chance to get rojas and it bounces away
from muncie
josh will stay put at first base rojas
two for three
coming back in with a 2-2 pitch
and getting him with a fast ball two-out
two good shots to the inside corner
slightly up above the belt ties him up
gets him to miss bessie deals another
one-two and strikes him out with the
fast ball so
puts two on and then comes back and
strikes out two bars denied a strikeout
looking and single to right field
barnes hits one well towards the left
corner it's down and it gets to the wall
ramos
[Applause]
[Music]
up two down here in the seventh inning
here comes justin turner
turner swings and he belts one to left
field deep this ball's back this ball's
gone a home run for justin turner
5-1 dodgers as turner blasts his 25th
home run of the season
working on his second inning he had a
clean top of the eighth
[Applause]
high fly ball no big deal for cody
ballinger mick's leg goes six up six
down and the dodgers have won their
fourth in a row
they've outscored their opponents in
that four-game stretch 21-5
and they shut down arizona they only get
one tonight giants keep on winning but
the dodgers do too and they stay within
two and a half games 17 games left in
what is going to be a fun sprint